[Music]
Alexandria is with us in Atlanta hi
Alexandria how are you hi I'm good how
are you better than I deserve what's up
in your world okay so I just have a
quick question so I'm 23 years old and
I'm currently working the baby steps on
step number two I'm just trying to
figure out if I should slow down on my
baby step number two to save up to move
out how much debt do you have pretty
much 43,000 okay and what do you make
and I make 35 okay
and how long have you been out of school
two years just about okay so you've been
living at home for two years since
graduation oh yes and you said you're 20
23 23 okay all right yeah I would I
would it's going to slow down your debt
snowball when you move out as well
because obviously you're gonna have
expenses that you don't have now yeah
and they're the only possible
explanation for me telling you to do
that is what it does for you as a person
not what it does to your baby step two
because I found as my mind were your age
they would you know come home and some
of them and spend a little time at home
while they kind of got situated they
didn't have student loan debt but while
they got situated and then when they
moved out and had their own apartment
with roommates or a house or whatever
and they were splitting up bills and
they had to go buy groceries and it was
a different thing something happened in
their emotional maturity and they were
already smart and advanced and like you
are and articulate I mean you just
called a radio show with 14 million
listeners you're pretty poised you know
so you know I mean yeah that's pretty
cool so you're not you know you're not
some backward kid or something you know
so I really think that you're still
gonna see this leap in your view of the
world your emotional maturity when you
do this and I don't know how quickly
that will turn into income the benefits
of having moved out how quickly that
will turn into income but
but I know it will long-term and so
maybe it may mean you pick up an extra
job in order to pull off some of these
things and get that budget on paid off
but yeah I would set you out just for
your sake not you didn't tell me your
parents are bad you didn't tell me there
was conflict I didn't hear any of that
and so I'm not even reading that into it
I'm just saying there's something that
happens when you're on your own
it just changes things you gotta get
your own mail out of the mailbox you
know I mean it just changes things and
and all for the good all for the good
there's something there's a dignity in
that that changes who you are and I just
yes if you were my own daughter I would
recommend you move out and I have done
that actually they were dying to get out
but but we loved having them there we
did I mean we are kids we get along
their kids and we did when they were at
home that they come back home for a
while and and they're just easy to get
along with it was fun it's a fun time we
didn't want them to go but yeah it's
good for them it's good for them hey
thank you for calling in appreciate you
joining us this is the Dave Ramsey show